comment ça s'appelle brut brut oui ça
s'appelle brut c'est un truc de tu
trouveras ce que cette ville est sur les
réseaux sociaux que c'est quoi être sur
les réseaux sociaux
vous êtes sur facebook sur twitter si
j'en ai il ment mais ils me disent ils
pas jeûner 3d facebook pendant pendant
six mois j'en ai trois matches je sais
même pas ce que c'est c'est depuis
personne peut m'expliquer je demande
qu'est ce que c'est être sur facebook
qui allongera le ils font ce que vous
êtes en train de faire ta d'iris marre
et il me l'expliquent pas qu'on passe à
autre chose comment on va faire
et puis du coup je sais pas ce que c'est
facebook je ne sais pas ce que c'est
twitter alors je sais que c'est mondial
mais je sais pas ce que c'est que les
réseaux sociaux voilà mes ci dessus je
suis sûr qu'on m'a dit guy roux tata
tertre un contrat faisant j'ai même pas
ce que c'est qu'un compte mon compte en
banque je sais très bien ce que c'est
mais acompte à facebook ce parce que
c'est bonjour c'est guy roux pour brut
vous êtes entraîneur de l'équipe de
france de la semaine oui mais elle n'a
pas joué à cause de la pente nba la page
web où les parents de malades nos
députés l'assemblée et le sénat c'est eh
ben non c'est plus que l'assemblée
générale
ouais j'ai eu monsieur v range bélier je
crois et je viens vous jouez pas lui
c'est un footballeur oui il y en a le
meilleur
les deux meilleurs c'est baroin et
muselier deux avant-centres il aurait pu
jouer c'est fort commentant celui qui se
présente dans nord la xavier bertand
c'est un numéro 10 il était déjà un peu
rond parties jouées mais c'est un très
bon footballeur il avait joué en cadets
nationaux contre la contrebande tonna
est là et d'enfiler possible avait
coaché alors j'ai eu edouard philippe
aussi mais une fois semble
par visiblement ainsi aussi non aucun
alors avec que j'ai aucun mauvais
souvenirs ils sont adorables pour parler
souvent avec avec avec humour des boîtes
de nuit c'est qui le joueur que vous
avez le plus traqué dans les
discothèques ça je vous dirais presque
que c'est un secret professionnel non
oui ça c'est vrai c'est absolument vrai
nom au bal d'abord en division d'honneur
et c'était pas les discothèques c'est lé
bal comment je faisais à ce moment là on
pouvait lire les compteurs donc je
passais à 20 heures devant chez eux je
lisais le compteur je notais je repasse
à 7 heures du matin je savais où il
avait été si j'avais été à 54 kilomètres
c'est qu'ils étaient à saint florentin
j'avais donné dès la liste des des
numéros d'immatriculation au péage et la
dame donnell ce qu'était passé et leur
c'était le moment où il y avait des gens
encore dans les cabines manar ya plus
personne dans les cabines serait fat et
les sorteurs moi j'ai appelé ça les
sorteurs faisait pas de vieux os dans
mon équipe
les videurs de boîte de nuit aussi avez
votre numéro et vous à pied précis que
c'est l'heure c'est leur histoire
elle aidait les doubles quand j'arrivais
le
le disc-jockey mettait un disque qu'il
connaissait et il se cachait partait
dans les toilettes il partait nithart là
par derrière mais ça ça voulait dire guy
roux est arrivée dans la boîte
ouais c'est cherchez-vous vrai cachet
vous barrez vous parce que vous y alliez
pas pour faire la fête vous y alliez
pourra oui complètement des fois j'en
faisais trois dans la soirée et alors
ils ceux qui ne savaient pas c'est que
les videurs et et hamoir il m'appelait à
8h30 le lendemain matin visait y avait
un tel attelage à la tête j'étais
complètement informé à chaque fois on va
monter après vous faisait aussi de la
prévention par rapport aux rapports
sexuels des joueurs ouais ne pas avoir
débat alors là ces matches là on a pas
de vérité scientifique là dessus c'était
très à la mode quand j'étais stagiaire
pro est par exemple un ancien
international m'a dit si j'avais pas été
marié avec une femme si si chaude
j'aurais eu 50 sélections au lieu de 20
bon après mais moi j'étais jeune homme
j'ai fait des essais pour ce qui me
concerne je voulais me le dire la veille
ça me s'amenuisait pas beaucoup
s'amenuiser pas mais l'avant veille je
devenais vrai tracteur un diesel pur je
pouvais courir indéfiniment mais plus de
dunes plus de mal à voir avec 48 heures
je savais ça donc qu'est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai fait des stages de trois jours
coronel pour avoir les deux nuits
précédentes j'avais été dans une île de
cuba qui s'appelle cayo largo est une
île magnifique j'ai fait passer un
séjour balnéaire formidable et
et à 5 heures du matin la police
stoppent n'étaient pas prévenus ces dix
mots de français monsieur le
comment il eu beau le monde le le patron
quoi vous devez vous voir
on doit vous emmener déjeuner avec le
monsieur castro si on est allé dans la
la maison d'accueil des étrangers
et là il y avait une grande partie du
gouvernement il y avait deux fidèles
bien sûr il y avait raul
il y avait des grillades qui se
préparait mais qu'est-ce qui vous voulez
fidel castro alors il y avait en est
venu à ça bien sûr il me dit voilà les
lamas jeunesse joue au baseball et au
football américain c'est des jeux des
états unis ça me déplaît souverainement
si on m'a dit que vous aviez une grosse
influence que vous le saviez développer
vous venez ici
je vous met de nos conditions de vie
très agréable et six en deux ans vous me
faites passer une partie de la
population au soccer de ma peau brûle en
âge préscolaire au soccer je vous donne
une île
j'ai écouté vraiment compte sur moi puis
j'ai un contrat je ne peux pas je ne
peux pas je dis non tout de suite on m'a
dit merci de votre franchise si vous
réfléchissez vous pouvez me rappelais
enchaîné pas rappelé